good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation usually weather
often with our speakers we have their
books out in the lobby for you to buy
but if we had all the O'Reilly books out
there there probably not be room for
people to get by and profound fans for
each one of them I suspect these are
deeply geeky books and this conferences
and is food camps and the maker fairs
and make magazine I've been an editor
and I guess these days I'm being a
curator and it used to be the editor
sort of kept out of sight the editor
that new yorker was a mystery for many
years for many people who is that what's
on his mind
Chris Anderson Ted Naik is Ted's
conferences are re as a curator and the
important thing to know about creators
and editors and publishers is some of
them have an agenda and that's kind of
boring once you know the agenda but the
thing they're good at is knowing what's
going on the stuff that you see that
they produce the books that they bring
out the conferences that they put on the
people they invite to the conference's
are the best or the most interesting or
the most accessible of the many many
more people and things that they know
about and so when you really want a
sound intellectual active reflection
what's going on in the world ask a good
editor a good publisher a good curator
and we got one of the best here tonight
Tim O'Reilly
thanks very much thanks very much I want
to say first off just I'm very honored
to be here the very first place that I
tried to get published when I was a
budding writer was in Stewart brands
coevolution quarterly and I just want to
say I have always been a huge fan of his
work and I've tried to follow in his
footsteps what I want to talk about
today is going to be informed both by
what I am thinking about in the
technology world but also in the spirit
of long now looking back both at my own
personal history and also looking back
in time some of you may know I was
originally trained as a classicist so
looking back at a little bit Greek
thought and then for the towards the
future but it's going to be kind of a
historical look at how I came to think
some of the things that I think as well
as what I'm thinking about I started a
lot of my talks with this wonderful
quote from Edwin schlossberg who said
the skill of writing is to create a
context in which other people can think
and it's a lot of what I do in my work
as Stewart says as an editor curator
writer I try to frame things in a way
that people can see them and often
what's going on in the world is obvious
in retrospect but not prospectively and
it's by framing them differently that
we're able to see what's going on so I'm
going to talk about a number of things
that are probably fairly familiar to
many of you but I'm going to try to
frame them in a way that you can see
them anew and the biggest thing that I'm
talking about is really the convergence
of computing and human potential and the
way that it is taking us towards
something that you could call a global
brain now when you hear that you
probably in this group you probably
first think oh the singularity you know
and all the stuff you've read about that
but that's actually not what I'm talking
about and by the way I in kind of
preparing for the talk I found a
wonderful little tidbit about the
singularity you know we usually
associate that term with Verna vinji or
you know Ray Kurzweil but in fact it was
first articulated by John von Neumann
you know as as George Dyson has reminded
us almost everything that we think about
in technology today was first
anticipated by John von Neumann so Stan
Elam in 1958 recounted a conversation
that he had with gentlemen know him and
he says our conversation centered on the
ever accelerating progress of technology
and changes in the mode of human life
which gives the appearance of
approaching some essential singularity
in the history of the race beyond which
human affairs as we know them could not
continue so you know that notion that
somehow we're heading towards a future
that's very different is a powerful idea
and it's one that I think has captured
the imagination of a lot of people we
also have all kinds of dystopian visions
in popular culture of what this sort of
potential future global brain might be
whether it's the Skynet of the
Terminator movies or The Matrix we have
from Kevin Kelly you know who's very you
know dear to many of us this notion of
the Technium as a new order of life
wonderful you know Kevin has got some
wonderful thinking about how technology
is taking us forward to something new
this is a piece I pointed to called
evidence of a global superorganism you
know and he talks in this pieces I think
2008 about an emerging superorganism of
computers
I really recommend his new book what
technology wants and it's very
consistent with my thinking but it's not
really computers I want to start with I
want to actually start back in the early
70s
when I was working with a guy named
George Simon it came to be when I first
met him he was a Boy Scout leader
actually and he later went on to become
a workshop leader at Esalen there was
this huge ferment in the 70s something
that you know if some of you may
remember we called the human potential
movement and it was really about how do
we tap into something you know inside
that will make us you know more better
and yeah I was just a kid but I did
actually when I was 18 years old I
actually co taught workshops at Esalen
with George he was a you know wonderful
brilliant guy kind of crazy you know
when I kind of talked about some of his
ideas would go wow this is just a weird
footnote but almost everything that I've
accomplished I actually learned from him
he kind of taught me a way of seeing
fresh and I'm gonna talk to you a little
bit about that and actually the very
first book I published was a
transcription that I did of George's
notebooks he did these little you know
pocket notebooks where he wrote all the
stuff he was thinking and you know it
was published in addition of I think 500
copies I actually put it out by
subscription it was kind of very early
you know paper Kickstarter so to speak
and this is after he died in an accident
but his you know key notion was that
language was a map and that we could
actually create maps of human
consciousness both you know in history
and as it went forward in time and he
had all these you know very complicated
maps in the little introduction to this
book I wrote something like you know
George was a little bit like the guy who
discovered fire he had all kinds of
stories about what it was and most of
them were probably wrong you know but no
matter what anybody who had fire they
got it from him
and that's how I felt growing up he kind
of taught me something so even though
everything he he said was probably wrong
there was this inner truth to it and I'm
going to talk a little bit about what
that was he started with a guy named
Alfred Korzybski the founder of general
semantics which was another bit of sort
of pop you know you know kind of the
kind of pop intellectual culture that
we're all
today except this is in the 1930s and
going forward and course in ski was the
first to articulate this notion that you
know we really need to understand how
language shapes and frames our thinking
you know cause if ski literally thought
that many of the pathologies in human
society were because we had bad language
you know when you think about racism
we're actually calling people names and
we're not seeing below the names to the
real person that would be a typical
example here's an example from my own
life I moved to Sebastopol and you know
in 1989 and I hadn't really been a
country boy and I'd look out in the
field and I'd see grass after a few
years of having horses and learning the
names of things I would see oat grass
alfalfa orchard grass rye grass and I
was able to make those distinctions and
I had names for them and I could talk
about them and that ability of language
to enable us to see was is a big part of
this notion of language as a map the
course Lipsky had this other idea
probably the line he's most famous for
is the map is not the territory you know
this idea that that if you get it wrong
you kind of get caught up in your map
and you don't actually look anymore
what's real and crisp ski actually had
this as kind of an experiential practice
he had this little device that he called
the structural differential which he had
people kind of try to identify when they
were talking or arguing he'd say where
are you on the structural differential
and you would kind of try to accustom
yourself to getting a sense of for that
so the structural differential began
with a parabola
you know quasi point was reality itself
is infinite right and then the circle
dangling from that parabola was our
experience of whatever that infinite
thing is you know which is limited you
know we only are sensorium only takes in
part of what's actually out there and
then we attach labels to it we name it
right and so you can kind of see that
that that process you know this is the
real world
open-ended parabola the the experience
and of course there were multiple
circles in the structural differential
because each of us there's only one
thing out there there's one parabola but
there's many experiences of each of us
has a separate one and then of course we
each have these different sets of labels
and maps and stories about what that is
so George kind of being a typical you
know sort of syncretism of the 70s sort
of mashed that up with the integral yoga
of Sri Aurobindo who kind of had this
story about the super mental you know
consciousness that was going to come
down you know and was the future of
humanity and George kind of said oh well
actually kind of that's like course it's
key you know the that infinite parabola
that's this super mental future of
humanity and we bring it down into our
experience and you know we bring it down
into our experience and and then we we
label it and so on and we tell stories
about it and George actually came up
with another way to represent this which
was to which was to draw a you know what
he called his quadrant system you know
where he represents the first quadrant
is the the beingness of the thing then
you experience it and then you map it
you come up with a story about it and
then he added another element which is
that you integrated into yourself and it
becomes part of who you are and he had
this story that kind of said okay what
we've added here is this notion that we
become something as a result of what we
know and how we think and what we bring
in from the outside and you know he also
kind of made the point that this happens
at a species level so he believed that
this happens to the species level as
well as at an individual level so you
know we're collectively the sum of all
that's gone before us our human
experience passed down incorporated you
know in in ourselves in culture and he
also had the notion that human
consciousness is still evolving so I
kind of imbibed all this stuff when I
was a teenager and then I went to
college decided specific
to go into classics because I was
interested in this notion of the
evolution of human consciousness I was
influenced by books like Bruno Snell's
discovery of the mind you know snail
pointed out things like the fact that
you know the Greeks didn't really have
words like even body and soul you know
they talked about parts of the body but
there are no words for the complete body
they have six or seven different words
that seemingly map to things like you
know soul you know like psyche you know
but psyche actually just meant breath
you know if you actually study the
language they use psyche to mean you
know the breath came out of somebody
when they're talking about somebody
making a decision it's for example
Athena speaking to somebody in their
thumos you know it's it's a completely
different sense of what a human being is
than what we have today when you when
you look at Homer and yet yeah by 400
years later in classical Athens in the
Golden Age you know every thing about
the way we think of a modern human being
is they're fully present so he tried to
sort of say look over this 400 years
something really happened in the
evolution of how humans think of
themselves and how they experience
themselves even you know this notion of
free will of agency you know it's not a
single point anywhere in Homer where
somebody is described as making a
decision you know somebody does
something because the God spoke to him
or moved him in this organ the FAMAS or
you know so on and so forth anyway so
it's kind of interesting the he also
pointed out the relationship to the gods
you know was a way of describing the
world in terms of kind of an almost
animistic quality you know Aphrodite I
mean how who doesn't experience
Aphrodite Aphrodite is is really a force
that we all see you know the gods were
sort of a way of explaining the world
and that gave way to a different way of
explaining the world over
the next you know few centuries and that
way of explaining the world had to do
with more process of thinking and logic
and discovery and it was sort of
interesting because of course you know
Socrates was put on you know put to
death for irreligion he was you know he
was conceived inthose or all the
religious rites he was somehow
threatening to the idea that the gods
were what moved us he was somebody who
said no no you actually can in yourself
think about these things you can come up
with your own ideas and that was a
revolutionary idea I was also back in
college I read this book the savage mind
by Claude lévi-strauss father structural
anthropology and he talked about the
notion that the you know sort of what he
called the savage mind it was a little
bit like a handyman who explained the
world in terms of the things that you
know that are to hand you know totemism
which he focused on you know you're kind
of explaining that if you have this kind
of spirit it's because you're you know
you have the spirit of a cougar if
you're if you're like this is because
you have the spirit of you know an eagle
and then he kind of compared that to the
engineering mindset so I saw that and I
kind of put it in this of George's sort
of framework about thinking about the
evolution of consciousness and I was
sort of trying to figure out how all
these things related and I started
thinking well George had this notion
that the next stage of consciousness was
something bigger and I said what's that
like and I actually ended up in my own
thinking tying that into the poetry of
Wallace Stevens you know who had this
notion that you know truth is actually a
kind of a fiction that we persuade each
other of and that it's ultimately
aesthetics that is you know the future
of kind of human cognition it's not
actually that this sort of engineering
mindset that we find an objective truth
it's actually this notion that you know
reality is an exercise of the most
August imagination and I love that idea
and and it kind of stuck in my head and
you you'll see why I shared that with
you
when I come to the end of this
presentation so my you know 1975 Harvard
Harvard honors thesis was about
mysticism versus logic in Plato's
dialogues there were a bunch of ideas
there where people would say why does
Plato explain this with this fantastic
you know mystical imagery you know and
it must be because he was influenced by
the pythagorean's and I said nonsense
you know I know exactly why Plato
describes things like Justice with this
incredible flowery language because when
he was first thinking about it that's
exactly what it was it was a new idea it
was powerful it was numinous it was full
of juice of course you described it that
way it was like wow the experience was
Wow and now we rehearse it and we kind
of go oh yeah okay got that yeah and I
read in a book you know and you guys
know that the first time you experience
something it has power and later on he's
boring all right you know so you know it
was kind of that that sort of
psychological insight that I I tried to
you know put an inject into that
classical discussion so anyway as I
mentioned George had this notion that
the next global the next stage of
humanity was a kind of global
consciousness and of course this was a
very current idea in certain circles in
the 70s some of you may remember TLR de
Chardin you know his notion of the omega
point and the you know the newest fear
and the future of humanity it was sort
of the spiritualists singularity of the
70s and yeah this continued really into
the 80s you know you guys may remember
the harmonic convergence of 1987 you
know we were all going to be taken up
with this great you know global
consciousness you know so but all a
bunch of New Age mumbo jumbo right you
know so I I thought was kind of but you
know fast forward to 2003 you know I
kind of put all that behind me got
involved in the computer industry and
and you know wrote computer manuals and
got involved in open
software and then started you know kind
of being an industry storyteller for the
computer industry and around 2003 I I
gave a talk and I'm actually I found
some slides from an old talk I was
giving a talk called the open source
paradigm shift and I was kind of
explaining why I thought that the open
source and the Internet was actually
changing all the rules of computing and
you know I started with the notion that
the killer apps of the internet were
these sites like Amazon and Google and
actually MapQuest which obviously went
away and eBay but you know I said you
know it's not just software it's it's
info where you know the editorial
content is part of the user experience
users helped build the product the
product changes everyday the internet
not the PC is the platform and then
there was this other kind of you know
really important piece you know I
started using the image of von
kempelen's Mechanical Turk to explain a
fundamental way that computer software
of you know this new generation was
different from say piece any previous
generation of software and it was the
idea that the programmer was still
inside the application you know and for
those who don't know von kempelen's
Mechanical Turk was a chess-playing
robot that you know was introduced in in
1770 by Ludwig von Kempelen at play
would play against all comers actually
Charles Babbage played against it and
lost and it actually got him he actually
was part of what got him thinking about
whether computing a real computing
device was possible it wasn't revealed
till 1820 that was actually a hoax it
just hide a really good chess player
inside this thing and he would work it
by knobs and levers and this came to me
in actually 1998 when I was writing a
paper about the importance of the perl
programming language which was the first
of the modern scripting languages some
of you may know you know Python and Ruby
and PHP or becoming important languages
on the internet well Perl was the the
first one then I went to my authors and
said what do you use Perl for and this
one guy Jeff Friedel who worked at it
was the author of my book on regular
expressions worked at Yahoo
you know finance yahoo.com they said
what do you do all day Jeff and he said
I write regular expressions to match up
news stories to ticker symbols and I
thought oh my gosh there's a guy inside
that application you know you know and
so I actually started you know going
talks this is actually one of the secret
sauce you know that it's there's people
here and then a few years later Dale
Dougherty you know kind of came up with
his term web 2.0 which was about the
second coming of the web after the
dot-com bust and I started using that
term to describe the characteristics of
those applications that hits of are
these sites that had survived the
dot-com bust and gone on to succeed and
to distinguish them from what went
before and what did I say again these
are slides from in this case from 2005 I
said they're using the Internet as a
platform for harnessing collective
intelligence you know so here I am you
know 20 years after that so the New Age
episode kind of saying the same thing
again just for a different reason and so
maybe there was something in that 70s
vision after all and to explain what it
might be you know I want to go back to
course it's key he had this wonderful
term he used called time-binding
he said human progress is dependent on
time binding and the first tool for time
binding is language that's our ability
to take something from the here and now
and pass it on over time and space it's
the sort of the essence in a lot of ways
of the long now idea here you know we
are actually able to capture something
and pass it on to people who are not
present and if you think about the
evolution of that you know you can think
about human cotton the evolution of
human consciousness is actually the
evolution of our ability to transfer
ideas and information from mind of mine
in spoken language written language mass
media the Internet and you start seeing
for in something like Twitter for
example the ability of a new meme to
rise up and spread very very quickly
remember for example when Occupy Wall
Street burst onto the scene and you look
at Twitter hashtags
they're really kind of like new thoughts
in this shared space that we're all
having Danny Hillis another long now
member you know actually wants explain
this beautifully when he said global
consciousness is that thing that decided
that decaffeinated coffee pot should be
orange you know you think about it how
there was a brand color for a Sanka and
then somebody else adopted that and it
kind of went from there it's actually a
wonderful essay from 1958 on this same
concept called I pencil how many people
here in the in the audience have ever
read I pencil google it totally worth
reading it's sort of an account a
first-person account written by a pencil
yeah and it says you know I'm this
seemingly simple object and yet there is
no one of you who could make me you know
and it's really about the way that we as
a culture have this vast distributed
intelligence and that's another aspect
that you know what Danny was talking
about here you know clearly this is
evolving in some interesting ways you
know we saw with the Egyptian revolution
last year you know the ability of people
to share ideas and memes and inspire
each other to action we haven't
necessarily had the outcome that we hope
from that but interesting process we
also look at something like Wikipedia
you know as a tool for collective
intelligence this is when we had the
great Sendai earthquake in 2011 this was
the initial Wikipedia entry a single
line in you know broken English an
earthquake occurred the earthquake
possible to create regional tsunami on
the zone and over the next few months it
evolved in this powerful way you watch
it you know just as thousands of people
contribute and this thing turns into
this full-featured Encyclopedia entry
michael nielsen in his wonderful book
reinventing discovery which is a book
about you know sort of collective
intelligence and scientific discovery
says Wikipedia is not an insight
pedia it's a virtual city a city whose
main export to the world is its
encyclopedia but with an internal life
of its own
and I think that's a really interesting
way to think about collective
intelligence
you know another wonderful example of
collective intelligence at work came
into play after the Haiti earthquake
last year there was a project called
mission for six three six it was
coordinated by the State Department but
involved all kinds of incredible
cooperation between far-flung people
using this hodgepodge of tools you know
you have this earthquake in an area
where people buried there's no Maps you
know they're trying to say how do I get
help and people start use their mobile
phones
you know State Department got a short
code for six three six set up and so
people were out there saying oh we need
you know help here there's somebody
buried under a house oh wait there's no
map well OpenStreetMap came in started
mapping you know the the the the the
slums
so that actually be locations that they
could you know send in then they're
sending in these messages but the people
are sending them in are speaking Haitian
Creole right they don't actually speak
English you know and the rescuers are
all speaking English well they used
actually CrowdFlower and Amazon
Mechanical Turk to reach out to the
Haitian diaspora community to translate
the SMS messages into English so they
could send them back to the Red Cross
and the US Marine Corps who were there
to go you know dig the people out from
under the rubble and it was this amazing
you know exercise in communication and
coordination adhocracy as I think cory
doctorow wants you know defined it which
is kind of really interesting sign of
you know a collaborative collective
intelligence future that is probably
more interesting and exciting than just
the examples that i used in the web to
example you know of how google harnesses
collective intelligence on the web or
how social media does it's really put to
use but in terms of understanding just
how far this can go I want to move to a
different technology story I'm talking
about the Google autonomous vehicle
doesn't look much like a story of
collective intelligence but it actually
is you know you see because back in 2005
when DARPA issued the grand challenge
you know the winning car went seven
miles in seven hours all right
that was the state of AI and yet in 2011
Google announced they had a car that
driven hundreds of thousands of miles an
ordinary traffic you know what was the
difference you know was it just that we
had great breakthroughs in AI you know
kind of like you know intelligent
machine you know Watson beats humans
Google car can now drive you know
because it's so smart no actually it
turns out the real secret Peter Norvig
said we don't have better algorithms we
just have more data what data it turns
out that Google Street View cars were
recording every street you know they had
very detailed images very detailed
measurements you know one of the things
that Peter said it's a very hard AI
problem to pick for example a traffic
light out of a field of view of a camera
but it's trivial to figure out if it's
red or green if you already know that
it's there so in some sense the secret
sauce of the Google autonomous vehicle
is the recorded memory of augmented
human Street View drivers you know they
had people drive those roads they were
equipped with all these very very
powerful sensors and that memory was
recorded in the cloud you know so this
is actually you know again a collective
intelligence application you know so
it's AI plus the recorded memory of
augmented humans and that's really my
point the global brain is us connected
and augmented again this was something
that was articulated pretty early on in
the computer industry by guys who just
really thought far ahead of the box a
JCR Licklider was the DARPA program
manager who actually funded the original
work on tcp/ip but in 1960 he wrote a
book called man computer symbiosis
and here the hope is that in not too
many years human brains and computing
machines will be coupled together very
tightly and the resulting partnership
will think as no human brain has ever
thought will process data in a way not
approached by the information handling
machines we know today you know so when
you see something like Google which uses
you know millions of links made by
distributed individuals uncoordinated
and uses them to predict the best result
when you see you know this Google Street
View vehicle somehow fueling an
autonomous robot car you're starting to
see elements of this man computer
symbiosis so when I say we're building a
network mediated global mind you know I
really am saying it's us you know
connected and augmented it's not an AI
it's really a set of technologies that
connect us in new ways in the same way
that language connected us in a new way
writing connected us in a new way and
now we have a whole set of technologies
that are connecting us in new mates we
have a shared memory now in the cloud we
have a shared you know communications
network we have an increasingly rapid
ability for information to leap from
mind the mind we also have a lot of new
tools for creating feedback loops this
first showed up in the area of
advertising you know John Wanamaker the
the department store magnate you know
from the late 18-hundreds famously said
you know half of my advertising doesn't
work the only problem is I don't know
which half and if you look at what
happened
you know with Google pay-per-click
advertising they were largely able to
figure out which part of the advertising
works they are able to build predictive
analytics and say oh we actually can
close the loop and say yeah that won't
work that one didn't and they outperform
their competitors because they didn't
actually just sell ads to the highest
bidder they actually were able to
predict which ads would be most likely
to be clicked on so they were again
saying all kinds of information from the
millions of people who are coming to the
site in order to predict better what was
going to happen collective intelligence
at work but this notion of you know
solving the Wanamaker problem applies in
other areas I just published a paper
called solving the Wanamaker problem for
healthcare which is about all the
different ways that we're starting to
think about how we can create new
data-driven feedback loops and
collective intelligence to apply to
problems in healthcare and that's
everything from what the Affordable Care
Act is trying to do with medical
reimbursements to new strides in in
medical diagnostics you know Pascal wits
who's the head of GE medical diagnostics
you know pointed out that only one
percent of healthcare spent now goes to
diagnosis you know we kind of do it at
the beginning and then we you know we
kind of do treatment and that's the end
of it but the new model is no no we
actually are testing all the time you
know we try something did it work did it
not we're really understanding how to
create data feedback loops and actually
solve that Wanamaker problem in
healthcare we're starting to see it in
cities you know SF Park is trying to
build sort of sensor network you know
networked parking meters that will
actually understand what the city wants
to do in terms of availability of
parking spaces you know this is really
the future of the smart city this is
really fascinating sly sort of image
from Wired magazine last year of 24
hours of New York City 3 1 1 calls you
know we're starting to see this sort of
electronic sensorium which is really
again not just an electronic sensorium
it's an electronic sensorium that is
collecting the intelligence and the
output of of humans you know so we are
the input to the system and the system
is giving us new ways to collect our
common activity a really interesting
project at you know the sensible city
project at MIT where they built so live
Singapore in that whole sensor world did
a lot of innovation happening in that
space and it's really useful to put it
in this frame of man-machine symbiosis
new models for collective intelligence
big piece of this of course is this new
area called data science you know we
have a conference called strata which is
focused on the techniques for literally
extracting collective intelligence from
large amounts of the data exhaust of
humans another really key point that's
coming out right now is how important it
is that this data be real-time Jeff
Jonas at IBM adds to the analytics this
wonderful commercial that he wrote he
did for IBM a couple years ago you know
we said would you be willing to cross
the street with information that was you
know I'm in a told of course the answer
is no and we're so we are increasingly
technology driving us towards taking
data from humans extracting meaning from
it and very close to real-time but
there's another aspect to this story of
human-computer symbiosis and that's
something that Vannevar bush in his
famous 1945 article as we may think
called intelligence augmentation you
know this piece really was a fantastic
prediction of the world wide web and
what we see in technology today you know
he said the human mind operates by
association with one item in its grasp
it snaps instantly to the next that is
suggested by the association of thoughts
in accordance with some intricate web of
trails carried by the cells of the brain
he said man cannot hope fully to
duplicate this mental process
artificially but he certainly ought to
be able to learn from it and he says one
cannot hope to equal the speed and
flexibility with which the mind follows
an associative trail but it should be
possible to beat the mind decisively in
regard to the permanence and clarity of
the items resurrected from storage of
course that's true you know you can
Google and in three clicks you can
actually read Vannevar Bush's 1945
article you know and of course in our
smart phones we're really experiencing
this next aspect of of you know Vannevar
Bush's vision of this information
retrieval intelligence augmentation by
our ability to effectively have an
outboard brain
how many of you actually refer to your
phone as your outboard brain and you
know and you know of course you know
even in areas like you know Watson which
is there now trying to you know retarget
from jeopardy to healthcare you know you
have this the real what this really is
is a vast information retrieval machine
for getting at the work product of human
intelligence you know I was meeting with
one of the people on the Watson team and
he made the point that Watson just reads
all the scientific papers that you know
all the medical papers that other people
can't get to and it then sort of says
Wow
you know have you thought about this
doctor you know and you know Randy Khan
the IBM doctor the doctor who's working
on this program he says Watson makes
suggestions not decisions but his point
was that it in the three seconds that it
takes to come up you know come up with
the answer of Jeopardy question it has
time to process the equivalent of 200
million pages you know that's you know
really this incredible power of of
recollection and memory you know being
made possible through this new kind of
man-machine symbiosis and of course when
you consider something like Google glass
the promise is that it will in fact
become kind of a UI for this kind of
information retrieval you know where you
have massive systems that are using
really interesting predictive analytics
to figure out what information again
information produced as the sum total of
human intellectual output
you know retrieved and brought to the
fore now you might think oh this is just
a curiosity you know and I never wear
one of those but but you know this
notion of augmented humans really comes
up again in an unexpected concrete
context I want to point out to you the
Apple Store as an example you guys think
about you know I assume most of you have
been in an Apple Store I have bought
something there
and you know how many more clerks there
are in an Apple store than you know
usually everybody's using automation to
get rid of people and somehow Apple turn
that on its head and it's using
automation to build retail clerks with
superpowers you know where they you know
that you walk up and they you know they
scan your device they swipe your credit
card and bing you're done you know or if
you've tried you know squares pay with
square application you know you
literally can now walk into a store and
say you know say your name and you know
your credit card will automatically be
debited this is a really interesting
we're actually building new kinds of
augmentation new kinds of human-computer
symbiosis and the real notion here is
that exploring the possibility space of
human-computer symbiosis is really one
of the fascinating frontiers of the next
few decades and quite possibly the next
century now one question I started
asking myself is what is the economy of
the future look like in their recent
book the race against the machine Erick
Brian Olsen and Annie McAfee make the
case that you know many of the jobs that
have gone away are not coming back we
are in fact automating more and more
kinds of jobs and you know just take
this google autonomous vehicle if that
comes out you know there go taxi drivers
there go truck drivers you know and you
just repeat that across the economy and
you ask so what does the future economy
look like as we take away more and more
of the of the you know formerly menial
jobs and you can say all you like well
you'll just have to move up the food
chain and do more intellectual work I do
think that that Apple store example
gives you you know a really interesting
framework for thinking how you can make
even relatively low skilled jobs and
actually upskill them through
human-computer symbiosis you know I
think in addition to you know retailers
like Apple you'll see that in home
healthcare where people you can easily
imagine you know a combination of
sensors deep data backends and then you
know pete humans providing the
high-touch front-end
as a future economic model but it's
really important to think about this
because you know our economy actually
depends on a virtuous cycle it's just
like the water cycle or anything else
from ecology the economy also depends on
a cycle you need customers as well as
job you know on product providers and a
talk he gave a TED you earlier this year
Nick Hanauer gave made a wonderful case
he said I'm a very successful capitalist
but I want to tell you you know there's
a big lie out there and that's the
capital creates jobs
he said customers create jobs and if you
know people don't have enough money to
be customers no amount of capital and no
amount of entrepreneurial ingenuity will
allow you to succeed and so he kind of
gave this you know voice to this
ecosystem thinking and so that's why I
started asking myself well gosh if Andy
McAfee and Erin Oleson are right and
we're taking away a lot of the you know
jobs we're gonna see is our future one
of more and more income inequality you
know is basically a set of high skilled
people
and then a bunch of low skilled people
who kind of read out in the gutter and
you know we've got to figure out that
future economy so I started thinking
about some different areas about how
that might look and you know there there
are many many different angles but I do
want to focus on one and that is the
creative economy you know he might think
well that's just you know kind of the
world that we're all part of you know
someone like Stuart or Kevin writes a
great book and other people read it and
they get paid somehow but you know Cory
Doctorow had this vision that I really
loved in his first book down out in the
Magic Kingdom for something he called
the adhocracy and he really described
what he called an attention economy
there was actually an attention currency
called Woofie you know which was you
know just like hey do people like what
you're doing well it kind of turns out
we're starting to see that you know what
is kickstarter but kind of like the
alpha of that system you know I'm doing
something cool would you support me in
it and
sort of a hack for translating over from
the attention economy into this real
like you know this monetary economy but
even Kickstarter may not be the most
interesting example I've gotten really
fascinated by YouTube recently because
it struck me that YouTube may actually
be closer to having the real business
model for the attention economy than you
know Facebook or Twitter this particular
video is one that my grandson my
three-year-old grandson likes to watch
along with something like you know it's
been watched something like 24 million
times it's a video made by a
five-year-old and his dad his Thomas the
Tank Engine train crashes you know he
kind of has this big complicated train
set and he shows how he crashes his
train engine in various ways and you
know Huck loves to watch this it's it's
you know what yokai benkler calls peer
production you know and it seems like
it's sort of silly you know but what's
so interesting is that there is a real
economy growing up here and it's
actually technology mediated so I want
dad to learn more about this I went down
to a conference called VidCon which is
sort of the gathering place of the
YouTube creator community it was kind of
like going back to the early days of the
Beatles there were literally thousands
of screaming kids when YouTube stars
came out on stage and this is actually
you know a line of fans waiting to get
an autograph from a you know
twenty-something you know British kid
Charlie McDonnell who has a very popular
YouTube channel what was interesting it
was also you know crawling with agents
he used to be focused on Hollywood and
they're now focused on YouTube but
what's really interesting is you know
when you kind of understand how YouTube
monetizes so interesting this is a
pretty popular video it's been watched
15 million times but what's really
interesting is there's a music
soundtrack you notice I circled down
there it says contains content from you
know dig dis there was something like
that
that is but Google auto detects when
there's copyrighted content attached to
a video and you know you kind of think
well in the original you know business
model of Hollywood want it was like take
that stuff down you know well what's
really happening is they actually pay
the artists and the music companies you
know so I heard a fascinating story
about a pop star who I won't name who
now actually makes more money on YouTube
than on iTunes and most of the money the
star makes is actually not from you know
videos and tracks that are put up there
by the studios but from tracks that are
put up by it from videos that are put up
by individuals who just happen to use
this person's music as the soundtrack
Google auto-detects
and the money doesn't go to the person
who put up the video it goes to the
music company so this is a really
interesting native you know you know
attention economy where people make a
video you know somebody's wedding video
has 50 million views and some artists
suddenly magically made a whole bunch of
money because somebody made something
new in this remix culture that got used
and I think that's sort of an
interesting you know aspect of how this
sort of future collective intelligence
you know may monetize in a world without
traditional jobs it may be that really
is that we are starting to see the
beginnings of that attention economy now
I call these peer production economies
clo's-line paradox economies in homage
to a paper that Stewart published in
1975 called the clothesline paradox by
Steve Baer and you know Steve basically
was talking about solar energy at the
time you know he basically said we get
all these ecosystem services for free
and you know we forget about it you know
you put your clothes in the dryer and
the energy use gets measured and counted
you put your clothes out on the
clothesline and it seems to just
disappear from the economy and I started
thinking about this in the context for
example of open source software which is
really one of the first and most robust
pure economies that you know a lot of us
have studied and been a part of you know
and I thought about that I said
you know everybody thinks wow you know
there's a couple of companies that tried
to make money off of open source
software like Red Hat or cloud era and
they've done ok but not really a big
market then you look a little downstream
and you say oh wow you know companies
like Google and Twitter and Facebook
well they were built on top of open
source software so this is further
downstream market but then this this
next piece I got from this guy named
Hari rava Chandra and from a company
called endurance international group
which is the largest web hosting company
in the US they said well we're all built
on open source yes you're thinking about
like oh wow people pay you know 80 or 90
bucks a month you know for web hosting
and the like and yeah you know actually
actually I take that back I'm mixing up
my if you actually pay six or seven
bucks a month for your you know domain
name and your you know potentially not
very much for your web hosting and
effectively you're getting subscription
access to open source software but one
of the things that Hari said he said you
know the real impact of what I do is
that all these small businesses are able
to have a web presence and McKenzie has
done a study that you know shows 10
percent improvement in productivity of a
small business with a website so you
start seeing how this peer economy of
people sharing free software turned into
all this economic activity somewhere
else and I've been thinking that that's
really a model for how this next economy
is going to emerge people are going to
do things just because it feels good to
share and then someone is gonna figure
out how to monetize that sharing and
it's going to be indirect and surprising
in the same way that you know the impact
of open-source software has been
indirect and surprising you know we need
to actually start thinking about how do
we measure an economy in which value is
created but not captured by the people
who create it you know I been thinking a
lot about this because I look at what
happened in 2008 with you know our
financial system going off the rails you
know companies that were able to extract
a great deal of value from the system
without Korea
Annie and the other extreme you see
people you know working like Tim
berners-lee
you know creating the web giving it away
putting in the public domain open source
software creating all this value but not
capturing very much of it and it goes in
that same way as you know solar energy
into the ecosystem that we're all living
in and it is in fact monetized elsewhere
so you know Lisa ganske has a site
called the mesh which is really looking
at the sharing economy she now identify
as almost 7,000 companies that are
trying different kinds of business
models in that sharing economy I think
it's going to be a really fascinating
you know exploration of the future you
know we we have these new kinds of ways
that we're connecting sharing building
work product that is inherently
collective that comes from our shared
attention we see these sort of thoughts
that are going across this global brain
and some of them are worth keeping and
some of them aren't our old methods for
you know saying what was important are
giving way to new ones but what is still
true is that there's a kind of you know
generosity and joy and creation that I
like to think will still be a key part
of the future rodney mullen who's one of
the fathers of Street skating he was a
you know usually successful skateboarder
in the early days when it was a
professional sport but then he kind of
was the guy who invented a lot of the
tricks out on the street and he gave a
talk at thing was TEDx USC and he has
this sort of wonderful thing he says you
know Fame and money lose their allure
you know you know he quoted Richard
Feynman saying you know a Nobel Prize is
the graveyard of a scientific career you
know then then he said what really has
survived for him you know he'd built a
company and sold it and he'd all these
things but he said what's really
wonderful he said there's an intrinsic
value to creating
think for the sake of creating it and
this is beauty and dropping it into a
community of your own making and seeing
it dispersed and seeing younger talent
take it to level so you could never
imagine because that lives on I start
thinking about that as something to
aspire to in this future global brain
and that is that beauty and of sharing
and that's why I wanted to remind you in
closing of what I said Earl about what
might be the hallmark of that next stage
of human consciousness which is
creativity and the idea that reality is
an activity of the most august
imagination and i invite you as you go
forward into the future to you know
share what you do very profusely because
it will be remixed by others into
something new
rich and strange and that is the world
that we're building together thank you
prepare to the bar okay Jenna vodka
Kevin Kelly says should we have a backup
for the global brain and you know in
case it crashes yeah I think that's
gonna be really interesting the one
thing I would would say about that is
you know I've actually given versions of
this talk where my last slide is you
know we've only got one world now we
better get it right because I do think
that's one of the issues I think about
in the context of an argument I've had
with Ray Kurzweil over the singularity
you know one of the differences in
today's world relative to you know so
the past is that the torch could pass
from one region of the world to another
you know you could have stagnation in
you know one area for a thousand years
while civilization was progressing
somewhere else and then it kind of comes
back and there's an ebb and flow but
really as we build this one global
civilization you know if we have a crash
and history tells us that often there
are crashes you know that really isn't
somewhere else to kind of be still
progressing and you know come back and
pick up the torch it really is is a
crash for everyone and I do think that's
a it's a pretty serious concern so what
do you do about that
I mean panic sounds like the first thing
you know it's one part of me I try to be
philosophical about it because and
actually I remember this story of my
brother James told me about a trip he
was on in Antarctica and with a
conversation with you know a geologist
and someone was in a panic about what
was going to happen to the world and he
said oh the world will be fine it's us
you should be worrying about and you
know I do think sometimes that whatever
is happening is bigger than we are
and we just have to take it in stride
all Oppenheim asks what is the role of
privacy in the global mind you know I've
been thinking a lot about privacy and I
guess I'm fairly convinced that the way
we're thinking about it now is wrong and
in particular the way that privacy
activists are thinking about it now is
wrong there's so much utility that will
only come from shared data that we can't
kind of roll back the clock and say oh
no we're going to keep this stuff secret
and instead we need to move to a regime
that's much more like the way we handle
something like insider trading you know
there's no problem with you knowing
absolutely anything but in certain
context you just cannot use it if you
know it and so it's much more around
well what are the contexts
what are also what are the norms you
know how do we you know sort of punish
bad behavior as opposed to regimes to
say somehow we gotta lock this up behind
some imagine a wall where people can't
get at it we just got to say you know
you can it's too easy to reconstruct
data from you know so many sources you
know as we are connected constantly with
devices that are putting out all kinds
of data exhaust it's almost impossible
for us to keep certain kinds of secrets
let's not say that they aren't certain
you know things that you can really work
at keeping secret but in general a lot
of data that's previously been thought
of a private will become you know public
and shared and we're gonna just have to
figure out you know what can you do with
it if you have it versus what can you
not do with it I've heard that
healthcare and places like Germany for
example or somewhat crippled by the fact
that health care data is not assured as
much as it should be that's right all
right I think Europe's gonna really [ __ ]
it's really shooting themselves in the
foot so is this another yet another
shadow of the Nazi regime and communist
regimes and things like that no I don't
think the other thing I think it's much
more analogous to you know say you know
book publishers or you know music
companies trying to you know
you know play can can you and hold back
the tide and meanwhile the world moves
on you know and I think it's really more
that they're going to be left behind and
that they're gonna succeed so who are
the confident and sharing and not
surprised I see paranoid societies
versus the ones that are well I don't
think anybody has really you know
figured it out right I think you know
certainly not at a sort of overall
society level I do think there are a lot
of experiments that are going on where
people are building really interesting
useful services that depend on data
exhaust and this notion of collective
intelligence and people are using them
and the market is you know getting
smarter about that and the best thing
that governments can do is stay out of
the way
and you know I look for well you know
figure out what our actual harms and you
know figure out how to protect against
those harms rather than somehow try to
control the flow of information actual
harms what I thought yeah as opposed to
imagined harms we got so much more
wonderful to contemplate well certainly
for politicians imagine harm so it is
Iceland an example of a place that I
mean they made their genomic data
basically of the whole country available
yeah part of a business deal but it's
also part of a governance deal and
worked out well yeah it seems to make
sense to me yeah okay well watch that
one all right Ben morrow asks what our
major frictions that you think impede
the growth and expansion of this global
consciousness well I think you know I
think the whole privacy discussion is
certainly one of them I think the you
know probably the thing I worry most
about is that we're not applying our
collective intelligence enough to hard
interesting problems you know that we're
applying the triviality so Jeff hammer
Becker who was an early face book or you
know said the best minds of my
generation are trying to get people to
click on ads that's kind of a real
obstacle
that's why I've been out there other
than starving hysterical naked come on
yeah yes my a lot of the talks I give I
you know try to urge people to work on
stuff that matters yeah
and they respond right yeah there's a
lot of yeah but again part of what we I
think need to do is to celebrate the
people who are you know using this new
super power for good and celebration is
easier because of all this connectivity
and that YouTube they will be yeah they
have a line of people waiting to you
hopefully admire kevin kelly asked what
might be the downside and costs of
global symbiosis PS will there be an
escape button yeah I see you know I I
guess I would just sort of say first off
you know is they're huge downsides at
the same time this huge upsides you know
I think very much of that wonderful
story from Jared Diamond's Guns Germs
and Steel you know in the in the opening
section you know yayoi's question I
don't remember if I got that quote
exactly right but he's you know he says
how come you guys have all the stuff
you're so dumb you know and you know in
fact this you know we have actually I
think we're gonna have other you know
issues like that where there will be
people who will be opting out of this
sort of future society and they're gonna
have certain virtues and just like hey
it's pretty good great to live close to
the land and not be connected and so on
and then there's but there's other
advantages you know when I wasn't back
to the 70s a lot of us tried that yeah I
know it has yeah I I will say this you
know my my older brother when I was a
kid used to refer to me as the failed
hunter-gatherer yeah yeah I would say
you're nothing but on the notion really
being of you know like a nice thing
about this I was this blind kid who
least liberalized struck out a kickball
when I was in third grade you know which
is pretty hard to do yeah you know but
but you know you know I I had different
skills and I think in a similar way
we're gonna actually have we're gonna
have some different kinds of society
some of
which are more highly networked and
which people are going to you know
become different you know a you know
back to the failed hunter-gatherer you
know it's like you know we have people
who learn to read and then they couldn't
do things like ride a horse and fight
with a sword or shoot a bow and arrow
and you know or track down a you know an
animal in the hunt but they could do
something else and I think a lot of our
future is to say well we don't know what
you know we'll need to be good at but we
can be pretty sure that it will be very
different than what we needed to be good
at at least some parts of it will be
very different than what we need to be
good at the past so this may be
different metaphors here there's global
mind and global brain which anyway I
kept thinking it's what you're gonna
talk about I'm so disappointed okay well
let's talk about it now in one possible
distinction but Marvin Minsky wouldn't
agree is that the brain is someone of
there's a anatomy of the brain different
parts do different things you know two
sides parts of Manatee vision there's
you know and the mind feels more like a
one big bowl of jell-o so a global mind
slash brain would regions in some sense
specialize oh absolutely I mean again
it's a metaphor first off you know the
main point that I I think I'm trying to
make is when we think about the future
of kind of a future artificial
intelligence you know whatever it's it's
sort of like this is AI and so you're
saying it's not artificially I don't
think it's awesome it really is us it's
like we are b can't become a
multicellular organism in a new way you
know it's it's getting you know a
certain point this this process of you
know communication becomes sufficiently
intense the structure becomes sufficient
that we actually become something
qualitatively different and you know you
can look at you know again this notion
that
Meem can spread you know how long did it
take for that Sankar brand color to mean
decaffeinated I don't know but I imagine
it was a number of years and it still
hasn't spread everywhere you know
Twitter memes you know spread can spread
in a flash worldwide you know of course
that could happen in the days of you
know mass media as well but I think it's
happening much faster
can you imagine young of Greek gods of
this newest fear that you're describing
oh absolutely
who's there what do they stand for
Aphrodite is alive and well yeah yeah I
mean pornography rules than that yeah
yeah yeah so it's a really good point
this really goes back to your question
of subsystems you know the very first
cave art was all [ __ ] yeah yeah
3000 years of it now yeah yeah well it's
actually a lot a lot a lot of I'm sorry
I distracted a lot of hunting imagery as
well
I remember this fabulous line from Zane
Grey where he said man was born through
Rome to hunt and to slay yeah yeah
there's that whole that whole you know
the anyway the gaff the gods of the
global consciousness who are they yeah
and goddesses hmm interesting
well they're probably the the same old
ones you know that there's certainly a
goddess of wisdom when I was kind of
growing up you know as a kid into
reading The Iliad and the Odyssey I was
you know Athena was always my favorite
the goddess of wisdom how is she get
expressed in currently I think that I've
probably hear in the long now now now
how is this a really good question I
have to think about that how do we sort
of expressed that that quality of
sagacity and
in sight Jonas Salk added a definition
of wisdom is the ability to look forward
as if backward mm-hmm that's a good one
you took that at heart here
it's a really good question of is that
still is that something that we actually
have only still as individuals do we
actually have collective wisdom I think
it's probably a good argument to say
that what we have right now are
expressions are probably lower impulses
you know we don't have you know we have
kind of that that sort of impulse and
sensation and the interest of things you
know or what are driving us you know
this certainly there's some pretty
vicious gods of old oh no question
and are there vicious expressions one
can see from this kind of oh oh no
question I mean you look at you look at
how you know hate spreads just as easily
as anything else you see you know kind
of our next speaker Steven Pinker will
see the record shows that basically hate
and justice violence and so on keep
going down mm-hmm
and that may map against the
increasingly connectedness of that could
be people a tree which way in which case
I mean what you're always looking for
just think everything's going to have
good and bad expressions you know as
Kevin Kelley likes to say as long as 51%
or expressions you're glad of and that
plays out over time you win mm-hmm and
you think these things that you're
describing have that quality you know I
guess I would say that you know neither
I think the the you know just as there
are good and bad individuals there gonna
be good and bad impulses in all of us I
don't know what will predominate you
know and I suspect that what
predominates will actually go through a
range of possibilities
you know it is sing here for example I
was in in Istanbul last year and kind of
just immersing myself in a little bit of
history there and so how hard is it that
there was a culture that survived for
you know quite a long time in which the
way that they you succeeded to the
leadership was by killing your brothers
you know and the one who survived was
the next ruler I mean it's like what a
foreign culture you know so you look at
the range of human experience of what we
consider to be normal at one time or
place is pretty wild and I think in a
similar way you know as you know we look
forward into this you know increasingly
connected future they're going to be
things that are going to seem very very
unfamiliar to us
and very strange Dmitrich Nealon asks
how do you see the field of information
architecture changing relative to
collective intelligence what is that
O'Reilly well I guess looks to the
future on the developing apparatus I
think the thing that I would just say as
a sort of framing metaphor the notion
that you want to build systems that are
afforded more collective intelligence is
probably the you know kind of the key
principle and you know I gave a number
of examples not in really a coherent
list but as I said you know exploring
the possibility space you know when you
think about you know the Apple Store and
the Google autonomous vehicle as two
different expressions of collective
intelligence you go wow you know you
would never have thought of that and so
for me information architecture is you
know kind of how do you define that and
you know capture you know the you know
the design of these kinds of systems
yeah I think on the web we figured out
quite a few design patterns for
collective intelligence you know like
okay you get people to review and rate
and
share but you know this new and
surprising developments all the time you
know the whole notion for example the
Kickstarter had of you know kind of
harnessing well this will only get
funded if you you know there were ways
they're doing crowdfunding before but
they kind of think they got it just
right you know so that it happened to
work there's so many kind of good
surprises like Kickstarter yeah and so
few really scary surprises
this sounds like better than 51% yeah I
think that's I think that's fair but
again I would I wouldn't entirely go
that far like if you look at the scale
of the bad surprises
they're probably greater you know take
take the financial crisis that is sort
of a sickness in the global brain you
know the financial system you know is
actually ahead of the consumer internet
in sort of harnessing you know
collective data building these since
that synthetic instruments that work
again turning BOTS loose to you know do
things with that data and they basically
used it to basically rip the rest of the
world off and you know so I kind of look
at that and I go there there's a really
good example of a pretty serious
pathology you know in the global brain I
think I look at Goldman Sachs and I go
there's certainly one of the you know
the avatars if you like of of the global
brain gone wrong and
and I would love to see ya when I see
these wonderful efforts you know we're
you know we're trying to harness
collective intelligence to solve you
know disease or you know how do you
debug problems like the the financial I
mean part of what they seem to have done
has gone beyond real-time and just so
real-time of nano range of trades and so
on so as a programmer a person who helps
programmers program a better world how
do you approach a systemic problem like
that in the global consciousness that
turns out to be problematic how do you
well detect and undo the boat I think in
some sense you need you really start to
have to you know reengineer the whole
system you know what's really happening
is that you know financial players are
really gaming the system and there's
really nobody in charge to fix the
system you know do we and what you've
just described as a system which will
not even remotely permit anything or
anybody to be in charge right you know
so you can't look at that and you go do
you end up have to have a really bad
crash and then somebody builds it over
yeah one of the things that's really
interesting to me I've been thinking
about this term I uses algorithmic
regulation you know if you look at say
the way that spam is regulated on the
Internet
that's you know the beginnings of you
know kind of a an immune system response
to a pathogen and you know works a lot
like you know biology you know there's
basically you recognize the signature of
something new and hostile and you and
you know you fix it you you know so
there's this constant search for
homeostasis in some sense and you
compare that to how government
regulation works you go well it's just
you know it's badly broken you know
somebody puts out some rules and there's
no method of enforcement you know I
think ultimately you know the financial
system needs to be algorithmically
regulated in the same way that spam is
regulated on the
you can you kind of say what are the
outcomes that we want and and then you
you basically managed to that you know a
good example of this I I remember having
a conversation with Nancy Pelosi
not long after Google did their panda
search update and it was so in the
context of SOPA PIPA and all that kind
of stuff in that's just see what sopa
sopa Stop Online Piracy Act you know
which was this sort of attempt to get
you know Congress to you know put out
new intellectual property laws to quote
strengthen IP on the internet and it was
interesting you know Nancy Pelosi kind
of said well you know we have to satisfy
the interests of the technology industry
and and the movie industry and I thought
no you don't you have to get the right
answer
yeah like I I just recently mentioned
the Google Panda search update which is
when they sort of downgraded a lot of
the people who are you know building
these content farms and putting out
low-quality content in order together
you know you know page views and clicks
in order to make money and not to
satisfy the users I thought gosh what if
Google had said oh yeah yeah we have to
sit down with Demand Media and satisfy
their concerns we have to make sure that
30% of at least 30% of the you know the
search results are crappy so their
business model is preserved you wouldn't
do that you'd say wait no no we have to
get it right and I feel like you know we
don't actually have a government that
actually understands that it is you know
has to be building a better platform you
know that starts to manage things like
that and you know we have the best
outcome for the the real users yeah so
the founding fathers were programmers
they're doing telly they were as this
elaborate cybernetic system with tax and
balances and all this cool stuff and
you're waiting in to.gov and city yes
and things like that
Oh to see a little bit about why and how
and what the future of adjusting
governance might be well you know it
seems to me that we're reaching a point
where
the way we've governed ourselves is
fairly broken you know it hasn't scaled
very well and in particular the you know
you know dominated by special interests
and the like and and you know it's
really clear we actually need to come up
with some new mechanisms that actually
harness some of this collective
intelligence for purposes of of
government and I think that is going to
be one of the great challenges that
democracy sort of the Greeks invented
and yeah it sort of works and that's it
right game over
well you know it sort of works the
question is we don't necessarily really
have a democracy we don't really have
even ever public anymore we have a
plutocracy and you know I think we do
need to fix that I think one of the
things that we actually are going to
find is that you know we don't
necessarily fix it all at once we fix it
in pieces cities yeah and I think
insidiousness is one place that you fix
it yeah and I think that we have to
actually start you know moving I guess
in moving away from the notion that
politics really has very much to do with
governance you know you know to the
extent that we can fix things without
politics will be much better off and Jen
pahlka likes to say that you know you
know governments this vast ocean and
politics is a six inch layer on top and
you know changing that our political
leadership is a little bit like changing
the font on a menu and thinking that
you've actually reengineered the system
and you know we really have you know we
you know what she's trying to do with
Code for America is to actually get in
there and start building new systems you
know for engagement new systems for
opening up data again it's really
working at a very small scale right now
but ultimately I think you know
government is gonna have to become a
player in this global brain and we
actually are having a lot of success in
that in some ways at the federal level
here in the US you look at what Todd
Park the federal CTO is trying to do
with you know opening up government data
in the area of healthcare you know I
have to say you know the Affordable Care
Act is a real attempt actually to use
data to build feedback systems so that
we actually have better outcomes you
know this is huge experiment or set of
experiments to actually try to build
government programs that you know work
in this way that I've been describing
how do you get I mean the major thing
about writing code is detecting and
heading off bugs yeah this is not the
standard in government you write your
law we're gonna boycott Cuba for the
rest of the time yeah yeah yeah and what
would be a way to to sunset laws would
have been one attempt at that but is
there a way to the Constitution had a
whole bunch of really important
amendments shortly after it was written
yeah oh by the way we left out some
critical stuff they put it in and made a
big difference and then from you more
and more slowly probably do a chart how
long has been since one has had a
significant amendment yeah and there's
none significant being offered now yeah
so what you see is a kind of a sclerotic
you know
tightening up of apparatus yeah although
you know there's some good efforts again
in in that direction Cass Sunstein who
was at the Office of was oh I forget
what it stands for office of something
in regulatory he's mister nudge yeah
yeah exactly yeah co-authored with dick
Thaler of nudge you know he led this
really fascinating effort where they
went around to every agency we've got
you you have a you have to go identify
regulations that are you know dumb and
you need to clean out and they've
actually managed to clean out a lot of
clutter but I think that that's really
trimming around the edges I think we
actually need some fundamentally
different approaches to regulation
because in an odd way the closest
example that I've seen for government
getting regulation right is with sort of
a quasi government quasi governmental
body which is is is central banks you
know they actually the way they regulate
is is kind of like the way someone like
google regulates they kind of say I have
an outcome in mind I have a couple of
knobs and levers periodically I might
get a few new knobs and levers and I
tweak them yeah to get the outcome you
know I don't just so to say well this is
the rule and I'm gonna follow it
regardless of whether it has a good
outcome or bad outcome they go no we're
supposed to basically you know keep
interest rates at a certain level and we
want to have you know various things
that we want to have happen in the
economy and we have a couple of levers
and we keep tweaking them to see if we
can get where we want to go okay so you
know I think you know that's really how
I would love to see us start thinking
about government regulatory processes
okay so we've been talking about the
global mind yeah we're not we're far
from you know truly global you know the
point though is that that's the global
mind relate to global governance dealing
with global issues such as for example
climate change which is way too slow and
strange for democracies so far to deal
with very well yeah well in a lot of
ways the quote the market as you know
the market even worse of dealing with
climate change
well yes no I I think ultimately it will
wake up you know there are a lot of
players you know there's a lot of
contending forces no question you know I
expect there will be diabolical
moneymakers on climate change will want
it to get a lot worse
now that you folks are completely
desperate we got something that will
help you fix this it'll cost you but we
got a first and but you know for example
insurance companies are gonna be you
know pulling on one set for start
pushing on one side you know III think
the question is you know it still may
not be you know fast enough and it may
be too late but I do think that overall
you know there are some hopeful signs
you know and I used for me you know
the thing that bothers me the most is
that you know in an ideal world you you
do have a somebody who's exerting
judgment and I think that you know the
judgment that we tend to exhibit in
government is generally pretty poor and
captive to you know kind of looking back
again to submit to classics you think
about you know you know plato's
description of you know virtue as you
know kind of this balance between the
reason and you know this he basically
had the the mind is a charioteer with
these two horses of you know what of you
know passion and one of forget what the
second one was but you know just trying
to trying to you know get them to go in
the direction you want to go yeah it's
my brother James once said you know
virtue isn't remembering what you really
want and unfortunately you know we have
government that's kind of where the
horses are driving the chariot and
there's no charioteer hey since what
Plato would make of current
circumstances he was kind of down on
literacy
well yeah plato was kind of enough job
in a lot of ways yeah I and you Chris he
never really know you know you know what
what was Plato in there but Plato for
example you know believed in the
enlightened despot he actually had an
experiment where Dionysus of Syracuse
was his pupil and he you know he turned
out to be an absolutely terrible ruler
and so you know Plato when he tried to
put his ideas of the ideal Republic into
practice you know produced a monster
Plato ever say oops no I don't think he
did but you know Dionysus was the guy
who actually the arrays heard the story
of the story of Damocles mm-hmm that was
Dionysius and his grand you know his
prime minister was Damocles and Damocles
said oh how wonderful it must be to be a
king and you know that was when
you put him in the chair with the sword
hanging over his head he actually lived
in Syracuse on his little pal SIA he had
his bedroom surrounded by a moat with a
bridge they could take up you know he
was terrified that he was gonna be you
know be killed he he it was really this
sort of despot and yet he was here he
was you know played a star pupil
last question building on one from Kevin
Kelley will we be able to understand
manage or steer global intelligence that
operates at a scale so far beyond ours
so but far beyond our individual III I
guess I think if you take the analogy
far enough there is no you know when you
say we you know you're showing that
you're thinking of us as individuals and
that's kind of like asking you know as
we became multicellular organisms you
know one of the cells is here we can be
able to control you know what this big
multi cellular organism does and the
answer is no you're not you know I'm
sorry you're part of it but you're not
in charge anymore and I think you know
going back to that notion of the
singularity as this idea that will be
this AI that we no longer control no I
think it's going to be is this you know
the system that is beyond our control
and again that goes back to you know
really that that 1958's a eyepencil
these guys saying like look we're
already there you know in making
something like a pencil you know it's
this collaborative activity spread all
around the world he read that essay it
was you know I would came from here and
somebody here did this to me and
somebody here did that to me and no one
person you know put this thing together
and I think increasingly you look at
that out you know there's gonna be a lot
of activities that you know only exist
collectively and you know you you know
it's this kind of goes back to that
privacy discussion you kind of go well I
want to take my data out and go home
well then you don't get any of these
services because they only exist when
you have a lot of people together and
you know your data is only meaningful in
context you know and this is kind of
like you know the question of privacy
again you know talking with John Madison
who's the chief medical information
officer at Kaiser you know and he was
kind of pointing out like what we're
gonna we're you know not far from the
point where
you're gonna want to have your complete
genome as part of your medical record
and you go that's great but you know
it's really only useful if we can
compare it to everybody else's you know
so it's very well you can go well we
could keep it sort of secret locked up
there and you can Ollie sure but you
know fact is we gotta somehow actually
extract meaning from it it's it's gonna
be a collective you know intelligence
problem once again and I think that the
you know the that really is the
challenge that that future of you know
collective intelligence applications is
a future in which the individual that we
prize so highly actually has less power
except to the extent that that
individual is able to create in a new
Mindstorms I guess if I'd kind of gotten
further with this talk you know I might
I might have ended up kind of tying that
that thought of the creative economy
into this you know how how will we
influence this global brain you know
what we actually the way will influence
is is seen in the way that people create
these kind of viral storms right now
they're just around
oh isn't that cool you know it's a funny
cat video or it's a you know where it's
a political movement whatever but we're
gonna start getting good at that you
know people will be able to command
you know vast amounts of attention and
you know direct you know large groups of
people through you know new mechanisms
I'm trying to think of the cell metaphor
there and you know the cells couldn't
really complain they're not in charge of
this larger entity the cells pretty much
stay the way they are the cells of this
entity people who engage get into
activity with the global mind are
rewarded for it yeah and that's why they
do it that's why they keep that it's why
they get better at it and by and large
they're all volunteers you know almost
all volunteers which means they're
having a good time and something keeps
getting better for them or they would
get bored and go away that always happen
that's right so this is not like the
cells who stayed the same as the body
became more and more complex these are
our cells that are themselves becoming
more and more complex and gaining
complexity not only and how they relate
to life with all these cool tools but in
the complexity that they are absorbing
by participating in this huge complex
event yeah and largely and enjoying that
so this is a you talk about in Vannevar
Bush and so on talk about human-computer
symbiosis it seems to be have this other
quality from other symbiosis ease we
know it's not a singularity probably but
it is some rapidly self-enhancing set of
processes yeah yeah it's so interesting
to know I actually think that some
people are going to be enhanced and some
people are going to become less capable
as a result in the same or in or along
certain axes again kind of going back to
the failed hunter-gatherer but that's
the story in research machine which I
just remained so I'm sort of aware of it
and John Henry goes up against the steam
hammer yeah and steam hammer wins the
John Henry Ellis John Harry the winds
but he breaks his heart so he loses and
the steam hammer carries on and John
Henry doesn't do that anymore yeah but
there are other John Henry's who are
designing the steam hammers and they're
doing fine and this is the point that
the authors and race against the machine
make that loses is the people who race
against the machine and who wins are
those who figure out how to race with
the machine yeah I think there are a lot
of people in that category and the
horrendous shift that we're seeing is
that shift from well it's a double shift
one is the shift from racing against and
afina racing witness being rewarded for
that and the machine itself getting
richer from doing that but the end with
an amazing line which is that this is a
deeper shift there economist dismal
approach to life to be an economist
because everything is based on the
economics of scarcity and they're saying
what just happened is that we're now
dealing with in economics of abundance
you know and that is a fundamental shift
you know which they say there's also
fundamentally beneficial yeah if if we
harness it correctly I mean I think one
of the you know risks in the old you
know in industrial economy was we kind
of say okay well I'm gonna use this to
you know take costs out of the system
and you know early in the industrial
economy you had people who you know took
thought for you know growing the
ecosystem you know Henry Ford paying
workers more than than he had to in
order to so they could afford his
product
anybody also had people who fought for
there's the line better work about how
the robots that built the cars don't
have to pay union dues and then Walter
Reuther says and by the way they're not
gonna buy your cars either yeah exactly
you know and I think that that's a
really really important point and so we
have to actually start thinking about
how that whole ecosystem works and and
you know I do think that the sharing
economy is going to be kind of
interesting you look at things like
Airbnb you know where people it starts
out well you won one level it's just
like wow we're just you know people
making a little extra money on the side
by renting a room or whatever but it
really moves up at the high end to
people who are creating experiences for
each other you know the most popular
kickstand on Kickstarter the most
popular Airbnb locations they're a lot
like Kickstarter's you know they're like
or a lot like the popular YouTube videos
somebody's crafted something special
there they're offering to other people
and again I just say that attention
early sign of that attention economy of
where we're you know when we're no
longer you know participating in that
old industrial economy we're just doing
cool things for each other yeah and I
think that may be an interesting sign of
where this is going
let's check back in ten
years from now yeah see how this stands
at that point you're really coming thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you